are you thinking about you were like
Army Hammer Army uh also a cannibal yeah
what did he say again was the famous
quote
he said like I'm Legit a cannibal
remember we were joked about that for so
long in his DMS he's like I'm
legitimately a cannibal look it up yeah
dude it says that the nerve of that guy
to come back and do an article and be
like I've Been Framed by cancel culture
it's like dude you literally said legit
a cannibal yeah I am 100 a Canada don't
you remember that yeah yeah I did you
could have just said I want to eat you
you know yeah but there's probably like
a lot of messages before that he
probably did say that at some point yeah
and she's like she's like yeah I want
you to eat me out and he's like not
exactly what I mean I want your feet and
your femur and your kneecap and your
thigh yeah you want to kiss him I want
to eat them yeah you eat them your toes
and put them on the grill what do you
mean a Black and Decker
6200 is that like a dildo like a fancy
dildo no it's a Black and Decker you get
it from Home Depot